[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute
schönen guten abend wir haben wieder das
wichtigste an diesem dienstag für sie
sortiert und außerdem haben kristin otto
und ich beschlossen täglich eine
deutsche goldmedaille tut unserer
sendung genau dasselbe wunderbar guten
abend hier sind unsere themen
die krise hält alle in atem scholz
erläutert beiden die deutsche haltung
makro sieht bewegung bei putin und in
der ost ukraine ist die außenministerin
an der frontlinie
söder schert aus bayern will die
beschlossene impfpflicht für
gesundheitsberufe nun doch nicht
umsetzen spd länder reagieren empört
von triumph im olympischen eiskanal die
rodlerinnen natalie geisenberger und
anna breiter räumen gold und silber ab
[Musik]
reisen für den frieden washington moskau
kiew dass die jüngsten stationen der
friedensinitiativen in der russland
ukraine krise und in berlin geht es
gleich weiter weil frankreich polen und
deutschland sich in der sache eng
abstimmen wollen bemerkenswert bei einem
usa-besuch hat der kanzler die
gaspipeline nord stream zwei als
sanktionsmöglichkeiten wieder unerwähnt
gelassen im gegensatz zum us-präsidenten
lassen sagt
es war ein antrittsbesuch in
angespannten zeiten und kanzler scholz
ahnte wohl dass man hier im weißen haus
klare worte zu russland und zu möglichen
sanktionen erwarten würde die fun scholz
auch nord stream zwei erwähnte er dabei
aber nicht wir werden diese schritte
auch alle notwendigen schritte ergreifen
und sie können sicher sein es wird auch
keine maßnahmen geben war den wir
unterschiedlich angeht der us-präsident
wurde da viel deutlicher
wenn russland einmarschiert also panzer
oder truppen die grenze übertreten dann
wird es keine nord stream zwei pipeline
geben wir werden das beenden
scholz reise wurde begleitet von einer
medienoffensive den vorwurf von
us-journalisten dass deutschland kein
verlässlicher partner mehr sei empört
scholz bei cnn
das ist absoluter nonsens und alle
wissen das beistand bekam der kanzler
vom amerikanischen präsidenten joe biden
zeigte sich überzeugt von der deutschen
loyalität
in deutschland ist einer von amerikas
engsten verbündeten wir arbeiten im
gleichschritt um russland von seiner
aggression in europa abzuschrecken in
kiew berichtet unterdessen der
französische präsident dass wladimir
putin ihn gestern zugesagt habe auf
weitere eskalationen zu verzichten
die krisendiplomatie läuft auf
hochtouren zur stunde werden makro und
der polnische präsident in berlin
erwartet
fragen wir nach bei unseren
hauptstadtkorrespondenten bei theo koll
momentan spielt sich alles in berlin ab
theo polen deutschland frankreich wollen
sich eng abstimmen ziehen denn wirklich
alle an einem strang
denn wenn der strand friedenssicherung
heißt dann lautet die antwort ja aber
die strategien wie man am besten an
diesem strang zieht die sind durchaus
unterschiedlich polen beispielsweise
fordert eine deutliche abschreckung
gegenüber russland vor allem die
deutsche entscheidung der ukraine keine
waffen zu liefern wird bei unseren
östlichen nachbarn kritisiert und auch
nord stream 2 da wünscht man sich einen
härteren kurs vom kanzler in den usa hat
kanzler scholz das wort nord stream
wieder kein mal benutzt er was steckt
hinter dieser strategie also olaf scholz
geht davon aus ist die bewusste
uneindeutigkeit bei den drohenden
sanktionen das beste mittel ist um
russland und putin zu beeindrucken
mittlerweile aber wirkt das merkwürdig
unschlüssig und bei kritikern auch
zweifel sehen denn wenn der us-präsident
neben ihm steht und im fall einer
russischen invasion das aus von nord
stream zwei als definitiv verkündet und
olaf scholz selbst gesagt hat alles
liege auf dem sanktionslisten bleibt es
rätselhaft warum der kanzler bei seiner
linie des nicht aussprechen
der stream 2 bleibt aber vielleicht
genau deshalb um nicht offensichtlich
von seiner linie abzuweichen makro
hingegen hat sehr schnell auf dem
europäischen fahrersitz platz genommen
ist deutlich vorwärts drängender und
erscheint es umso mehr je
zurückhaltender berlin zumindest wirkt
danke danke dir köln nach berlin zweiter
tag des ukraine besuchs der deutschen
aussenministerin annalena baerbock war
heute unterwegs im krisengebiet john
bass und dort das wissen sie verläuft ja
seit jahren die frontlinie zwischen der
ukrainischen armee und den von russland
unterstützten separatisten eine
bedrückende erfahrung nannte es berbalk
hinterher aus der umkämpften region
mariupol berichtet jetzt andreas künast
es sollte kein niemandsland geben in
keinem land aber das dorf scirocco soll
vertragsgemäß nichts anderes sein mit
schutzhelm und splitterschutzweste läuft
die deutsche außenministerin durch die
realität des abkommens von minsk der
vertrag trennt die ukrainischen kräfte
meter genau von den separatisten
1900 meter genau mühsam verhandelt
diplomatie trifft auf praxis berbalk
weiß wie die bilder wirken sie hofft
dass sie wirken in berlin moskau aber
vor allem in der ukraine
das nehme ich mit dieses gefühl dass man
tagtäglich dem risiko ausgesetzt ist von
einem scharfschützen doch erwischt zu
werden das ist unser auftrag als
internationale gemeinschaft genau das zu
verhindern die osze die den
waffenstillstand an der kontakt linie
überwachen soll berichtet berbalk von
veränderungen die kräfte auf beiden
seiten werden radikaler zuletzt wird am
sonntag ein tod der separatist gemeldet
gestern ein verletzter ukrainischer
sollte hat der krieg den alle verhindern
wollen hat längst begonnen deutlicher
symbolischer als an der sogenannten
kontakt linie kann berbalk nicht zeigen
dass deutschland auf der seite der
ukraine steht die bundesregierung will
keine waffen liefern aber auch keine
weiteren zweifel an ihrer
entschlossenheit zu lassen
am donnerstag sollen in berlin russische
und ukrainische diplomaten mal wieder
den weg zum frieden suchen er ist noch
weit und
eine personalie noch die das
außenministerium betrifft annalena
baerbock holt die chefin von greenpeace
die us-amerikanerin jennifer morgen in
ihrem ministerium erst als
sonderbeauftragte für klima später als
staatssekretärin für ordentlichen streit
in der politik sorgt gerade die
impfpflicht in gesundheits und
sozialeinrichtungen bis zum 15 märz
müssen beschäftigte etwa in altenheimen
und kliniken einen impf oder genesenen
nachweis erbringen ansonsten dürfen sie
nicht weiterarbeiten
jetzt hat bayern angekündigt die
impfpflicht nicht umzusetzen die
reaktion viel kritik und empörung britta
buchholz
es ist gerade mal acht wochen her als
die abgeordneten die einrichtungs
bezogene impfpflicht beschlossen nicht
nur die ampel parteien auch die union
stimmte dafür jetzt die kehrtwende der
csu chefs söder will einen bayerischen
sonderweg die beschlossene impfpflicht
soll vorerst nicht kommen uns geht es
allein darum die pflegenden nicht allein
zu lassen und nicht am ende dadurch
einen pflegenotstand zu bekommen nur
weil ein gesetz schlampig vorbereitet
vorbereitet wurde das gesetz auch in der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz und dort
rangen sie um eine gemeinsame lösung die
empörung über den kursschwenk der csu
ist groß allein ging es in so was wie
ein markenzeichen des bayerischen
ministerpräsidenten aber das was wir
jetzt gestern erlebt haben das schlägt
ehrlich dem fass den boden aus die
abkehr der einrichtungs bezogene
nebenpflicht ist aus meiner sicht
verantwortungslos und auch
rücksichtslose parteipolitische taktik
cdu-chef märz drängt sogar auf einen
bundesweiten stopp der impfpflicht für
pflegekräfte
doch sowohl in nordrhein westfalen als
auch schleswig holstein wollen wird
keine kursänderung
cdu-ministerpräsident günther
widerspricht klar dass haltung klare
kritik auch von der fdp die ständigen
kurswechseln aus bayern aber auch aus
der cdu kann kein mensch inzwischen
nachvollziehen nicht einmal die eigenen
bundestagsabgeordneten aus der cdu und
csu fraktion sind in der lage die
aktuelle haltung der union wiederzugeben
streit um die impfpflicht in der union
unter den länderchefs doch auch kliniken
und altenheime fürchten um ihr personal
was das alles für die impfpflicht der
pflegekräfte bedeutet ist fraglich sie
sollte eigentlich bald beginnen in rund
fünf wochen
und um alten pflegeberufe attraktiver zu
machen soll es in der branche ab
september höhere mindestlöhne geben
darauf hat sich die pflege kommission
geeinigt demnach steigen die
mindestlöhne schrittweise bis ende
kommenden jahres für hilfskräfte von
aktuell 12 auf 14 euro 15 und für
pflegekräfte von jetzt 15 auf 18 eur 25
außerdem soll es jährlich gut eine woche
mehr urlaub geben dann schauen wir jetzt
auf die korona zahlen die weiter steigen
dem robert koch institut wurden 169
1571 neuinfektionen innerhalb von 24
stunden gemeldet das sind 6
1958 mehr als vor einer woche
177 todesfälle kamen hinzu und die
sieben tage ins ident steigt auf
1441 bei labore und gesundheitsämter an
der kapazitätsgrenze arbeiten sind die
zahlen aber wohl unvollständig
ja wie sind die zahlen zu interpretieren
wo stehen wir in der pandemie da
informieren uns ja regelmäßig der
bundesgesundheitsminister unter chef des
robert-koch-instituts
letzterer lothar wieler wurde zuletzt ja
recht heftig kritisiert vor allem von
der fdp wil verbreitete heute einen
gewissen optimismus in berlin lauterbach
sieht die lage noch nicht unter
kontrolle
heike slansky
erst waren es gerichte die die 2g regel
im einzelhandel in einigen bundesländern
kippten dann zog die politik nach immer
mehr länder verzichten auf
einschränkungen der
bundesgesundheitsminister dagegen warnt
vor zu schnellen öffnungs schritten die
lage sei noch nicht wirklich unter
kontrolle
wir können also breite lockerungen wie
sie derzeit diskutiert werden zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt nicht vertreten ich
wundere mich über die diskussion die zum
teil in der politik jetzt zu beobachten
ist werden natürlich deutlich vor ostern
öffnen können aber wenn wir jetzt
schnell öffnen dann verlängern wir nur
die welle und schaden uns selbst mitte
februar könnte die welle frühestens
ihren zenit überschritten haben
allerdings seien immer noch zu wenige
geimpft vor allem drei millionen über 60
die schwer erkranken könnten ungemach
kommt auch vom koalitionspartner seit
tagen kritisiert die fdp lauterbachs
behördenchef wiener hatte über nacht den
status von millionen genesenen auf drei
monate verkürzt der gescholtene leicht
aus das robert koch institut arbeitet
wissenschafts basiert inhaltlich das
machen wir jetzt seit zwei jahren in
einem spot leute wie wir das natürlich
vorher noch nicht hatten und das wird
auch so bleiben er will hat man volles
vertrauen er sitzt ja auch erneut hier
und die also fdp das lasse ich
unkommentiert streit innerhalb der ampel
parteien lockern wann und welche
bereiche angesichts hoher
infektionszahlen werde das virus weiter
mutieren und zwar weltweit nur wenn wir
global denken und helfen die
gesundheitsfürsorge und allen ländern
entscheidend zu verbessern dann können
wir die entstehung neuer
besorgniserregende varianten
zurückbringen nächste woche beraten die
länderchefs mit der bundesregierung wie
weiter in der pandemie
der frühere papst benedikt hat heute zum
münchner missbrauchs gutachten stellung
genommen das ja auch ihm schwer belastet
benedikt bittet die opfer sexualisierter
gewalt um entschuldigung er spricht von
tiefer scham und großem schmerz den er
empfinde gleichzeitig wehrt sich
benedikt gegen den vorwurf als
erzbischof von münchen missbrauchsfälle
vertuscht zu haben bei seiner einlassung
zu dem ende januar veröffentlichten
achten habe er zwar einen fehler gemacht
nicht aber getäuscht oder gelogen
betroffene reagierten mit enttäuschung
auf die stellungnahme
ganz anderes thema mikrochips die
braucht man fast überall in der technik
sie haben sie zu hause in ihren
fernsehgeräten im smartphone- oder im
auto aber seit der pandemie gibt es eine
weltweite chip knappheit und das trifft
besonders europawahl produziert werden
die meisten halbleiter in ostasien
die eu will das jetzt ändern sich
unabhängiger machen und dafür viel geld
in die produktion hierzulande pumpen
anne gellinek berichtet ohne mikro chips
läuft weltweit nichts wenn sich in asien
pandemie bedingt die container staunen
geraten bei deutschen autoherstellern
die montage straßen ins stocken
mikrochips sind überall drin vom auto
über kaffeemaschinen bis zum
mobiltelefon
produziert werden die immer kleineren
und leistungsstärkeren halbleiter in
asien vor allem in taiwan die eu
kommission will das nun ändern europa
unabhängiger und eigenständiger machen
europa ist der kontinent auf dem alle
industriellen revolution begonnen haben
europa kann also auch der ort für die
nächste sein der ehrgeizige plan der eu
kommission ist es den anteil europas an
der weltweiten chip herstellung von
jetzt neun prozent bis 2030 auf 20
prozent zu erhöhen dafür will die
kommission elf milliarden euro an
frischem geld und weitere 32 milliarden
aus laufenden programmen beisteuern so
sollen chiphersteller mit üppigen
subventionen nach europa gelockt die
strengen wettbewerbsregeln dafür
aufgeweicht werden
die staatshilfe darf nicht mehr sein als
nötig sie muss proportional sein dh dass
auch private gelder fließen müssen und
sie muss europa als ganzes zu gute
kommen
der vorschlag bedeutet dennoch eine
zeitenwende noch nie hat die kommission
ein solches förderpaket genehmigt in der
aktuellen chip krise hilft es allerdings
noch nicht es wird wohl jahre dauern bis
die neuen fabriken produzieren können
er war bekannt als der ausnahme
unternehmer mit herz götz werner gründer
der drogeriekette dm ist mit 78 jahren
gestorben
1973 eröffnete werner in karlsruhe seine
erste etwas andere drogerie
selbstbedienung besonders fairer umgang
mit den mitarbeitern später ein bio
sortiment damit kam der erfolg fast 4000
märkte hat das dm imperium inzwischen
und nebenbei schritt werner bis zuletzt
leidenschaftlich für das bedingungslose
grundeinkommen
wir machen jetzt mit schönen nachrichten
vom sport weiter gold und silber im
olympischen eiskanal christi extrem
schwierige bahn die zweite rote
entscheidung spannend bis zum schluss
und dann jede menge freudentränen
natalie geisenberger zum dritten mal
nacheinander olympiasiegerin ein novum
und anna bereiter rast als debütantin zu
silber großartig
nach all der anspannung
bricht sich die freude bahn
natalie geisenberger gewinnt olympisches
gold nach ihren siegen in sotschi 2014
und in pyeongchang 2018 macht die 34
jährige ihren hattrick drei siege in
folge hier in young kin perfekt danke an
meine familie
oder ich hab ich nur geschafft und
gehört uns vor dem start die
konzentration ist sie ins gesicht
geschrieben besonders kurve 13 nötige
respekt abgab geisenberger bemerkenswert
ehrlich zu bevor sie auf der fast
anderthalb kilometer langen strecke zu
gold trust
und über silber jubeln anna bereiter die
olympia debütantin kommt eine knappe
halbe sekunde nach geisenberger ins ziel
und rundet das starke deutsche ergebnis
ab
mit ihrem fünften olympia gold zieht
natalie geisenberger mit der bisherigen
deutschen winter rekordhalterin claudia
pechstein gleich
[Musik]
und ebenfalls ein kapitel olympische
geschichte schrieb der österreicher
matthias mayer mit seinem heutigen
triumph gelang ihm als erster alpiner
skifahrer ein hattrick gold bei drei
aufeinander folgenden winterspielen
zuerst in der abfahrt und nun zweimal
nacheinander im super g
[Applaus]
sie ist der star der chinesischen
olympia mannschaft und könnte die
erfolgreichste der spiele werden mit
drei goldmedaillen lingua 18 jahre model
sicherte sich mit dem letzten sprung im
freestyle big air den olympiasieg
so nah können frust bei testo aus
frankreich und freude bei der chinesin
einen gut beieinander liegen dieser
matsuri hätte für das gastgeberland
besser kaum geschrieben werden können
denn jenseits der medaillenränge liegend
back to you in ihrem letzten sprung
einen sogenannten lex david sixteen
twenty den zuvor noch nie eine frau
gestanden hatte
chinas 18-jährige schnee prinzessin
geboren und aufgewachsen in den
vereinigten staaten hatte sich erst vor
rund zwei jahren für eine chinesische
staatsbürgerschaft entschieden
ihre stärkste gegnerin die französin
tesla konnte in ihrem letzten versuch
groß hauchdünnen vorsprung nicht mehr
übertreffen
schirge winken nun im slopestyle und in
der halfpipe noch zwei weitere anlässe
um bei der siegerehrung so gewinnend zu
strahlen
es ist echt unglaublich ab
danke christin so sonne ganz im süden
trüb ist es dann im norden mehr zum
wetter gibt's gleich von katja horneffer
gesundheitsminister lauterbach um 21 45
im heute-journal interview mit marietta
slomka von uns im 19 uhr heute dem war
es das haben sie noch einen entspannten
dienstagabend und gerne bis morgen
[Musik]
guten abend beeindruckend ist dieser
wolken wirbel sei hier vor island der
hat windgeschwindigkeiten von über 140
kilometer pro stunde mitgebracht und
seine wolken schleppe reicht bis nach
mitteleuropa heute nacht fällt so in
norddeutschland häufiger mal regen im
süden ist es zum teil auch klar und über
den schnee flächen am alpenrand sinken
die temperaturen bis minus 6 grad
deutlich milder bleibt die nacht unter
den dichteren wolken im norden mit 8 bis
5 grad und morgen wird ein sehr milder
februartag mit höchsttemperaturen
zwischen 7 und 14 grad und am mildesten
wird es am mittel- und am oberalp und
auch morgen ist es in norddeutschland
eher bedeckt und zwischen dem emsland
und der ostseeküste kann es auch etwas
regnen
richtung süden sind die sonnen anteile
etwas höher und am strahlendsten scheint
die sonne zwischen dem allgäu und dem
oberrhein am donnerstag wird sich an
diesem wetter noch wenig ändern der
regen zieht etwas weiter richtung
südwesten rein und dann kommt der
freitag da wird es markant kälte es gibt
schnee regen und graupelschauer
wahrscheinlich auch einzelne gewitter
bei zwei bis acht grad und der samstag
wird dann richtig sonnig guten abend